do you know how many kids feel less than  because he didn't have a chance to get  to school they're not you know they're  not this they're not that and then you  look at someone like Gary Vee and he  admits like he said in public that he  got D's and F's and we thought where he  is now do you know what kind of hope  that be it's a long game I was told  between 7 years old and 18 years old  that I lost that I was a loser because  this is what I got F City baby but when  I saw after City I knew inside that this  was not the game that I was gonna play I  was patient  I ate crow in that 12 year period while  the market and the Machine told me I  wasn't gonna win I knew or my outcome  was and you may now be in their 20s and  30s and 40s and the Machine the  marketplace might be telling you that  you're gonna lose but it is about  staying the course and putting in the  work and position yourself in the right  position to go out and win